hello welcome to the Maxi course of the
mathematical writing uh first order of
business we um
uh we transcribed the enrollment forms
that you filled out and these might have
typos so I'm going to circulate this
this sheet around the uh the room this
all when it comes to you just take a
look and see you don't have to read
everybody else's but look at your own
and make Corrections on it please and if
you if you should be on here and aren't
why not just uh just make a note on on
this sheet instead of doing it on the
enrollment form okay so that see can we
get this on TV so you know what it looks
like looks like this okay several Pages
where so please uh um correct this as we
hand it as we hand it around
thanks now uh let's see old business I
just brought a few things with me to
show you the first of all I had
forgotten the other day to bring this
book with me um how to write
mathematics um published by the American
maass society I believe you can you can
certainly get it from the society and
and uh and uh it should be possible to
order it through the bookstore and the
and Max Schiffer here the third author
is a amera Stanford Professor who who
contributed um and Paul hush's article
is the one that I thought was the uh was
was had the best humor in it and uh so
anyway uh I wanted to show this
one his collected works what in his
books well now I'm not sure he's written
so much um this book this article
originally appeared in
um in um let's see wait a minute
steenrod uh this this article originally
appeared in a French publication here
last some I think
this um Maran what does this mean
teaching okay teaching of mathematics
okay 1970 and then it's reprinted in
this in this thing and more honest title
would be how I write mathematics and so
on and so and it um and uh but I but I'm
not sure it might very well be be re
reprinted uh has several um uh points
like write good English um honesty is
the best policy down with the irrelevant
and the trivial and so on okay so he's
got um do and do not repeat you know all
these uh
um um the editorial wi is not all bad
use technical terms correctly use
symbols correctly Etc all all
communication is exposition that's his
uh that's his NE article in there and
and I wouldn't be surprised if it was
reprinted because it's one of the best
available if not the best on the subject
um then I I said something about using
mathematics in titles of Articles and uh
over the over the past few days I ran
into what might be the the record for
the for for the abuse of this rule um
and it was all started
by by uh gaus actually who's probably
the greatest mathematician who ever
lived and uh he he wrote this little
this this this paper here um in Latin
about the infinite series and then he
mentions the infinite Series in this
title part one he never did publish part
two but anyway this was this came out in
1812 and so uh then somebody else um uh
writes an article in a
journal uh few years later and here here
we have the same thing with two
displayed formulas In tha so other words
not only mathematics in the title which
is hard enough on uh on on all all
reviewing and information retrieval
systems but uh but here he has displayed
formulas in the title uh and so this is
you know on the case when the series of
the form y equals etc etc a square of
the form such and such has uh um and
this is a famous uh nice little paper
and then uh and then when when when kumr
wrote a few years later he had to do the
same thing uh you know so they putting
this so following Gus's tradition I
think it stopped about there but now
what happens when you have to put this
into the bibliography of a book of a
paper so well so I happen to be writing
a book now it refers to these to these
articles and so when I got to coloss and
so here I had to put it in now um there
we go
okay and uh and uh let's see where G
gets in
there um now I couldn't you know there
wasn't room on the line for for his
formula as it turned out he wrote too
many of things but but really uh when
when you give a bibliography you ought
to you ought to quote the uh the
original title in full um although um I
don't I I did look up these references
in other bibliographies and they usually
put a few more dots in the for in the
formulas than than the original authors
did one of those references you had the
Chevy Chef in rush and thenes yeah right
no this is spelled in French um this
isn't Russian Russian is cilic alphabet
and in French if you wrote it this way
it would it would be pronounced she
instead of CH and so they put a t in
front you know words different translate
transliteration schemes from uh from uh
cilic depending on what language you
speak and and and uh for example in
German you would you would use a a w to
translate a v
sound uh but in in Engish English uh and
and and uh a lot of times people will
use the Polish scheme which where a c
really means a TS sound and uh this this
means that and so um I I've um uh
adopted the uh Library of Congress
scheme for for transliteration when I
referred to a Russian uh a Russian
person now and I have to be consistent
this meant that uh shikovski had to be
listed under C
um although he's almost always given us
with a t because it because of the
French
tradition um and chbf there's H there's
at least 30 ways to spell chbf I think
uh and uh and and but I didn't use the
ceric alphabet here and I didn't use uh
and I I refer to a Chinese work I didn't
refer I didn't use Chinese characters
here I didn't take the time to metant
those
symbols um now um another comment I
could make about the biography here is
that uh I think it was Mary cla's
recommendation to uh uh to to spell out
the titles of the of things uh instead
of using
abbreviations um uh this will make the
book maybe two pages longer and it might
add a few sense to the cost of the book
but only two pages out of 500 that's
trivial and uh and it's much I mean the
purpose of the bibliography is not to is
is really to encourage people to find
these things in a library they're
wonderful thing not to impress people by
the length of your biblography but this
helps too if you want to impressed by
the
length um and uh and so but the main
thing is is to make it helpful to so
that people can can uh um find things
there and so uh like like Journal de
math now a lot of times people will will
you know JD maath and then uh they won't
know for that or sometimes they'll call
it Louisville's Journal which was also
known as cuz he was the editor uh um
there's this one here is
um
Jour this is this is really the first
great mathematics journal in in history
and this is volume three when he
published it here but this one um is
often called Journal F math and uh um so
you're looking it up and you you have to
know that convention if you if you don't
happen to realize it and every every
Journal has its own
uh
uh now now this is a a question about
capitalization um this is the way they
they capitalize it in on the title page
and they use upper and lower case and
this is what they do uh you can you can
probably see that um no actually in the
bottom of this page is still called K's
Journal K is the editor but uh on the
title page that's what he called it and
uh this is uh and and uh you can we we
can um start capitalizing things too but
I tended to to stick with the older
conventions when I when when I'm dealing
with the older journals uh so the now
here for example uh Royale was
capitalized I believe in the in the in
the Journal of the and and they they
keep changing the title of that
journal depending on whether it a king
in France at the time or not you know
but but uh the the uh uh what was the
other examples the um act uh the old um
uh Russian
Academy tended to uh to do things only a
few words would be capitalized so I
tried to anyway the main thing was to
try to to try to to to to in your titles
to be uh uh consistent with the um uh
with what with what the authors do I'm
even uh going so far as to try to uh uh
spel you know if the name is given in
full I I give the full name if it's not
if it's abbreviated I give just the
abbreviation of the name that the author
used at the time I don't know
we like what like oh here yeah well this
is this uh here in fact I had to slant
this this this logo here that was pretty
tricky uh um yeah but
um uh right and here I I couldn't I
still haven't been able to find this
journal so I but they didn't capitalize
the r there as far as I know in this in
in Berlin and so uh but I haven't got
the page numbers anyway uh the main idea
though in a in a in a bibliography uh is
to be helpful and not to be uh and you
can you can go on and and and overdo it
in many ways maybe I have here I don't
think so uh but but uh people give the
um uh like Mary CLA says in usually like
when I say Addison Westley I don't have
to say Reading Massachusetts where
they're where they're located cuz it's a
it's a well-known publisher but on the
other hand and sometimes uh uh there are
some Publishers that are un so so
unknown you'd like to give their you
know their their address and telephone
number uh in order to do it well okay
we'll talk more about that later if
there are questions on that but now the
main thing I wanted to do today was uh
was to go through the the homeworks that
were turned in um I I I I checked those
um and and uh there were quite a few
points of interest that that can you
know just to to sort of uh what do we
call it um lock up what we talked about
uh on the first three days by uh and and
then there are a few points that came up
that I didn't have in my notes oh two
other very quick things I do have uh uh
the other articles are referred to the
math the manual for monthly authors and
this article about ma making math
intelligible these are in the library uh
you could you can get them uh by asking
asking at the desk there's you know some
some xeroxes of this where were made for
your convenience okay now um uh these
homeworks are Anonymous I uh I I don't
plan to turn them back but uh or to or
to give letter grades on them and so on
it was just for practice and the main
thing I I'm a firm believer in in uh
learning by by not being afraid to make
make mistakes but just by doing and then
uh and then taking a look and and seeing
what could be possibly done better
afterwards so uh I don't reveal the the
names of the people who who did these
but we will put them on the screen and
uh just to to show some of the things
that I think are interesting about them
as I scan through them um in a in uh two
or three cases unfortunately the person
who who had this assignment didn't
really understand the concept of a
mathematical proof and so there were
there were mathematical errors in the in
in it now um uh that's uh um a shame
because I think they know that they the
high schools aren't doing the job they
used to and teaching how to Pro how to
prove things and so on in mathematics
and and uh it's it's certainly if you're
going to really be writing expositions
of mathematics you should um understand
some of the uh uh well you should
understand the principles of what really
constitutes a rigorous proof and you
know these words aren't just random but
they they do have to go into certain
patterns that that that uh satisfy logic
um uh on the other hand uh uh I assume
that you know that that's not the
purpose of this course is not to teach
how to make proofs the purpose of this
course is to talk about writing assuming
that you already know about proofs and
these people um then uh uh presumably
they had to do the assignment that I
gave them even though it wasn't one that
they would ever really want to write
about uh uh but if you if you are a
computer science student uh who who uh
uh wants to be successful you really
ought to ought to know about
mathematical proofs I think it's pretty
hard to get to go through life without
it in as as a good computer scientist uh
now let me just show you a couple of
those little errors here was um was a
um um okay this one is a little hard to
read here um anybody remember this
problem he says since p is not an in a
subn it must be the case where are we
here the case that P sub I less than P
subj for any I less than J and here
um uh that is not for any I less than J
that's for some less than J um there's
quite a difference uh in other words uh
if if you have if you violate a if you
violate three conditions that doesn't
mean that all three have been violated
it means that at least that one of those
conditions is is is true so so um this
it's not you know things that aren't in
this set of non-increasing vectors
aren't increasing
vectors they're they're just not
non-increasing and we getting more of
that anyway that's uh um uh one of the
one of the things that came out since we
can't read that one anymore let me try
another one here
um
um okay I've got a point here in this
case L of c and P equals c where C is
any element of capital c um now
that's that's just not not correct
there's no equation that says that this
that the L of c and P equals c in fact
this was uh here's you look at the this
the sentence here let us assume for the
moment that P contains the null Vector
zero as an element let us further assume
that is computed by letting P subj equal
0 for 1 Lal J less than m in Formula 2
that in this case L of c and P equals c
so so uh um where C is any element of C
now you know that word any again is conf
confusing but that's just first of all
there's no reason why you could possibly
assume that it contains the null vector
and you're supposed to the re the real
reason is uh in the mathematics here was
that you can let m equals z in the
definition and then that shows that that
the uh that LP concludes so so anyway
this this just indicates really a lack
of fluency in mathematics and and not uh
and uh and if if this were correct
mathematics then the writing uh is
something that we'll talk about but that
that's the main thing is is this the
subject of the course will be writing
and occasionally we'll have to uh use
the some of the um idioms of of of
mathematical proofs in order to make our
points but the similar things would go
for any any uh uh kind of mathematical
Exposition okay now let's look at this
um at this line that we just had here U
the person had equation and then then
crossed it out and changed it to formula
that was not my correction that was on
the on on the paper as was given in and
you see what what two is here um it is
definitely not an equ well it is an
equation actually H okay could it it so
equation could be used there but
sometimes uh the thing that you display
isn't doesn't have an equal sign it
might have a less than sign or something
so it's hard to refer to something that
says you know n less than five as an
equation uh so calling it a formula is
or a relation or a statement or
something like that is usually safer if
you but if it's an equation you can
certainly call it an
equation it's a definition that's that's
even even better yeah in definition too
and and putting the two in parenthesis
is what I would usually do but I or in
Brackets as whatever this symbol is here
how do you feel about just saying in
parentheses to in two um it in if it's
in parenthesis then uh then it yeah I
would I wouldn't mind that uh partic uh
and dependent on whe How
on the temple that I was trying to set
uh sometimes I I want to be a little
slower sometimes I want to be a little
faster depending on the the
environment um
now
uh let's see
uh we know that L of CP is a subset of
aan regardless of what CNP are as long
as I I put in this comma here um just
now commas to me are
are in indicative of something that it's
it's it's something that the reader
isn't supposed to be aware of but it's
supposed to help the reader uh because
it corresponds to a pause when you're
when you when you're doing it verbally
and
um uh and this would this would also
help to help help you know um uh what's
coming up without looking ahead and
that's very important for comprehension
as I said the other day there's there's
this one pass
on don't go backwards uh uh to reparse
the sentence aspect of things when we're
when we're writing we try to to to uh to
to have it so that a person can read it
without look ahead um and the comma
helps with this are we know that LS
regardless of what C and P are as comma
as long as C and P are both a subset of
n n to the N now this is an unusual
error here but C and P are both a subset
of of n subn i I would say both subsets
of of Ln to the N anyway uh okay now um
here's U here's an example of on the
bottom here is an example of something
we point out don't introduce subscripts
unnecessarily assume that capital P
contains only the element P subv now
why um why not just say that it contains
only the element
P we're introducing a new symbol why do
we have to introduce a new symbol with a
subscript uh at the same at the at the
same time um uh so um and it doesn't
have to contain only that element it
might just contain you know that this
element and many other elements that's a
mathematical error but okay now here
here we've got another another thing so
piece of V read P for that but now he
says PX less than py for some X less
than y and then on the b top of the next
page where p v
bracket R is the arth component of the
indenial vector piece of V now here I
should say something about computer
science notation versus mathematics
notation in in programming languages uh
the uh the component the AR component of
a of a vector is use Pascal says use
square brackets and um and that's uh
something that's easy for a computer to
understand a lot of people write paper
no I didn't see it in any of these
homework but people I've seen a lot of
PhD thesis where people will write a
asterisk for every multiplication sign
in their formulas and they go through
pages of derivations and we got these
extra asteris in there as if this makes
it really a
multiplication now now um when when
these high level languages came out alol
had what it called a publication
language as well as the rep as well as
the language that you actually submit
for to the computer and the publication
language suggested using subscripts for
for um uh subscripts I mean for indexes
and uh and uh
and you know uh suppressing uh the time
sign and things like that uh uh that
that was never really very very much
followed in the uh In Articles published
in Elo language because people wanted it
to be easy very easy to transliterate
their programs they never really wrote
uh uh 10 to the end with a superscript
but they would write 10 uh uh up they
some whatever algo symbol was they had
different different ones at different
times uh for powers of 10 and uh and so
on now um that's okay if you're writing
if if you're writing about a computer
program that's going to be submitted to
a to a computer but when you're doing a
mathematical proof that's that just
messes things up it's it's a a whole
bunch of clutter um it's not too it's
not really too bad to call PR R the r
component of a vector but I'm but most
of the time it's it would be much EAS
much nicer to just said P sub r as as in
the um as in the original thing another
point that this phrases is what about um
well this is kind of awkward here
because the notation is being introduced
uh in steps this means that something X
and Y are used and then they explain
what X and Y are and then they explain
what the brackets are in terms of R
which is which is yet another local
variable R here is is is introduced just
for this phrase uh R is a dummy variable
to refer to a general component and so
on so that becomes that becomes somewhat
awkward but it raises the a general
question that I that I think is worth
worth talking about and that is
um um it is it is natural in in
exposition to to to hold off introducing
some parts of your notation until after
You' said them instead of say in other
words I like the first point here
suppose we already knew the bracket
notation then I would definitely say p
of X less than P of Y for some X less
than y before I had instead of saying
this means that for some X less than y p
of X less than P of Y it sounds much
better even you get to the bottom line
even though you you even though you you
you're explaining the bottom line in
terms of of of of un undefined notation
because you get to the definition very
quick if this for some X less than y
would come up in another sentence a few
a few lines down then no no then then
the reader is hanging like what's X and
what's Y and so on but it's much better
to say set a sub I to zero for all I
than to say for all I set a a of I to
zero it it just you you it's so so much
more punch if you can say first what
you're doing and then and and say set a
sub I to zero well person doesn't really
know what i is but right away you told
it for all I and so and so then then you
got that through so um uh now um I had
some arguments with people on the
comprehensive committee last year about
certain wording of certain questions
where they thought that it was hanging
too much uh to to go by but but but uh I
do feel that that uh effective effective
communication often puts the the action
before the definition if the definition
follows real quick now here though here
it gets carried too far though I think
because first we have to Define X and Y
then we have to define the notation and
then that notation includes an R where R
is sort of in informally defined so you
have to break that into two parts and do
it in two in two
steps uh there was a computer language
called I
swim which stands for if you see what I
mean uh that was uh that was all based
on um on on this this wear notation
putting putting declarations after and
and it actually looked very good in
small examples and then on large
examples it was a total
disaster
okay all right um now the
uh but by the way those of you you
realize that I'm picking out most the
errors that I find in here and I'm not
I'm not going to exclaim about oh this
was good this was good so so don't so in
general I was fairly pleased with the
with the assignments that I got but I'm
trying to but I you learn more by by
doing something uh that's not that that
can be improved and so so I'm going to
be focusing on that when I bring these
up here okay well now here the very
first I say the first sentence should be
your best sentence right and right away
here we got two formulas without
anything in between them I think wasn't
that rule rule one or something in the
notes or something like that so uh
observe that by the definition of LCN P
comma C now it's just sometimes um this
is going to be confused as a single as a
single um phrase now mathematicians do
that an awful lot if you look in
journals you find that rule violated a
terrific amount and uh and uh if I were
you you know so I would instruct the
types Slater to put an extra extra space
after this comma here and I would train
them to put a quad after every comma for
these po mathematicians that don't know
rule one on the other hand uh uh I would
maybe it would be would be better to to
bring it right up next to the comma and
then ask the mathematician to correct it
on gy proof by putting a word in there
um so that they would learn um uh the
the the the the problem so anyway
um uh we have to reformulate this
somehow so that we don't have two
symbols right smack in a row now here
was another interesting thing it says
now assume for a contradiction that L of
c and P contained in Ace of n now that's
a peculiar phrase but um uh and it it's
not quite I don't I haven't heard it
before and it doesn't sound right I'm
not but uh it's sort of we're getting at
what we it's we're getting at the point
of we're going to do appr pro pro for by
contradiction but this phrase doesn't
seem to be a good a very good one we'll
see good ones as we come along later but
this is now assume for a contradiction
this is a something I I haven't got a
word for exactly what's wrong there um
now um that there is a p such that P not
an a subn by the definition of a subn
there's there's exists i j such that p i
less than J where p is is this Vector
now here um there's a question as to
whether or not when to introduce the
notation what is piece of I mean what
does pie of J mean um but um
uh uh I I raise it here not to suggest
that I have a um a definite uh solution
but that it's not it something it seems
that it might it doesn't quite work very
uh great flow here uh but if I had if I
if I make p if I give p with all its
subscripts up there there's a danger
that I'm losing the thread of the of the
argument by making this part this too
complicated on the other hand then
there's also a danger uh what that I
don't know what that that uh what P
andjr even though I have the wear coming
up rather closely here because that's
not the point of this construction it's
the it's the existance this such that is
terrible it should uh and exist goodness
I don't I said don't use those symbols
didn't I
well
um uh when you use three dots there
should be a common there to complete the
darn thing but uh in general um actually
how do you like Ellipsis uh punctuated
you ellip yeah yeah ellipses we talk a
little bit about ellipses the the the um
the the the other other things uh the
other books mention this too and I
didn't and I didn't uh say very much
about it now the the modern the the the
modern convention is settling down to
one that I think is very is very nice
but it's gone through different
transitions um at one time people used
only ellipses that were that were up
high and and and other time they used
only ellipses that were down on the line
and now they now there's a general uh
convention that I that's that I that I
think works well and that is to use use
three dots down on the line in a in a
case like this in a comma context or in
a multiplicative context so if you're
multiplying the things together uh you
would also put the the ellipses down
down in the bottom
um but if it's in a or you know a
semicolon type of context that's down on
the line but three dots that are that
are between um
uh uh between less greater than or equal
signs would be raised like that see this
that was that's done that's done well
there but here's here's three dots down
on the line and these are three dots up
on a line so if it's in a context of
plus signs or or relations um raise them
if it's in the context of comma if
here's a plus sign context you see
um and and and and repeat the operator
before and after the uh the dots you
have a a comment is there a space on
after that third dot after which this
here here down this one no the third one
no you were on the right equation this
one now what about this one no the the
dots the ellipses yeah is there a space
after that third
one well there's a space around around a
relation
usually go dot dot dot space oh well
okay now these dots are not if you if
you write on a if you would types set
three dots you'd find that dots are very
narrow and those dots and so there's
actually spaces to space them out but
now you're you're asking about this
right here at this point right oh yeah
um it there's a space before and after
those three dots uh just but that's not
the space that goes with the dots it's
the space that that's sort of before and
after the uh uh the greater than signs
well the shape the greater than makes it
look like the spacing is uneven oh
okay it I I can't vouch for this types
setting system um but it might be but it
might be a uh it it but it might be just
a uh uh um I mean look yeah here you see
there looks like more space there but
the one is a sort of a strange symbol so
you can't get it but the convention is
is to yeah the convention wouldn't
wouldn't be in certain extra space there
but it but actually if it's followed by
a right parenthesis you would put a
space there because otherwise it it it
looks like it needs one I don't know uh
there's uh all kinds of accidents happen
in formulas about spacing and and and uh
and you know there's there's rules
that'll cover 95% of the cases or 99%
maybe but if you write a lot of
mathematics this you're going to have
this 1% is going to arise once in every
100 symbols or something and that's once
every couple of pages so there will be
there'll be something where a little
space fiddling will will make a a small
Improvement and um I would say that
second that second or third order
correction but you can certain there's
certainly nothing against um improving
this the thing afterward um the uh the
most common error is to put is to have
three dots and then another comma
without enough space between here I mean
it would be very I I um I think probably
it it's in this uh probably uh in this
um Macintosh system here which probably
does
that well I don't know this is this is a
little too close to the semicolon I
think but there's there's worst cases
here you can see if you look in the book
later I don't
know
um whoops
what these these dots are too far apart
though it's it's not
that
here yeah there's something but it's
because these are too far apart more
than uh more than that the other ones
are okay
well um okay but the uh now that was
um uh something that that certainly
uh arises a lot I mean uh I guess V
Lyman wrote a paper when he was when he
was young where he was very prec he
didn't use three dots any anywhere in
the paper and so on but I think it was
hard to read uh than his other
papers where am I
now um here's a since we're talking
about type setting here's something
people I saw that somebody was using
Tech here and uh in order to get the
empty set symbol used a a
uh you know some kind of a back
a backspace thing okay well now there is
a there is a symbol in Tech called empty
set which solves this problem uh because
the the ordinary slash comes down below
the it's not centered in order to really
put over zero you'd have to you'd have
to shift it up a little bit um and
besides then you get a symbol that looks
too black because you got to take
actually the empty set symbol is is made
from a zero that's thinner so that it
doesn't you know and uh uh and uh puts
the thing on there but but uh
uh
uh some people use some people use
another another thing for empty set that
looks more like that and that and uh
tends to be confusing if you're also
using the Greek letter fi while this
symbol is more distinctive but that's a
uh matter of typography of what fonts
you have now um here's another thing in
Tech if you were doing this there's a
there's something in Tech called mid
which is which will put a vertical line
in the middle of a set notation and will
also leave space around it uh as it as
it stands here you just this looks like
a single symbol CC but it's SP but but
but but more properly if some if the if
you had said mid then you would you
would uh uh I mean the the actual Tech
Construction would be to get the brace
you have to write a backslash brace and
You' say C and you say mid and then you
would say C in Capital C and and close
it that was I'm not going to make this
of course in Tech but uh but the uh uh
there are there there are aspects of of
type setting that are covered in the in
the tech manual uh with with examples of
the of how to improve the spacing of
formula the thing I wanted to uh okay
now here's the I want to point out a
couple of good things here in this one
we demonstrate the second conclusion by
contradiction that's a that's a that's
very nice first I mean um uh uh it it it
tells the reader what's going on uh that
we that we're now going into the second
conclusion and and we're going to have a
proof by contradiction and so on um so
it was a good transition sentence that
that started things out and and kept
everybody in syn in sync um it uses
present tense
um we demonstrate you know or not we
will demonstrate so on um and we'll talk
more about tenses later I it it's okay
it's fine there's different ways to to
to to to do uh tenses um question yes
this is actually more typography but the
next sentence P not an element of
something is broken yeah this is p
subset yeah right but that's a line
break in the middle of a formula isn't
that bad right it's not it's not too
good in fact you had to pay a penalty of
of 500 I mean in other words it would
have looked very even worse without that
for some reason Tech there's a form
there's a there's you know Tech didn't
didn't do this uh easily uh and um uh
now of course I would solve it by
putting the word that right there um but
that um but as far as the the break is
concerned it was yeah it's um um it's a
it's it's an unfortunate break because
you come all the way back here and it's
a it's kind of a let down you see this
just this little one symol here anti
climax for sure um uh so I would but
anyway
um uh but I'm not sure about this that
this this seems a little to make it a
little bit wordy in this particular case
I definitely read the phrase yeah so so
um and and and and it and it spoils it
cuz we got a that right there so so um
there's already a that so that's not
that's not the solution uh so in Tech I
would just I would just might write my
formula then I put put I put this in in
Braes I would say p not not subset so on
um a and and braces tell Tech don't
break this formula under any
circumstances then you'll stretch out
the first
line
um and and that isn't really it's it's
this is such a nice short phrase here it
doesn't seem to be to be necessary for
me now but I I'm not sure why uh
sometimes I want it sometimes I don't
here I like this next sentence there
must be a witness to the unsorted of
elements of P this is a uh I mean this
is a uh um uh this is this is again a
helping the reader understand what we're
what we're doing and uh the witness is a
uh is a sort of a buzzword now in
certain branches of computer science
theory but uh uh still it's it's nice to
bring in vocabulary sometimes I think um
but now do you see a problem here um
some Vector p in p with two elements p i
and J such that and among
the no well mainly yeah but mainly
everything is elements this is what I
this is my main thing he's got elements
of capital P and he's got elements of
vector p and so these so I think it'd be
helpful to to distinguish by calling
these components okay
um among the then we then elements come
in here again um uh but then here it's
components of okay and so you know it's
better to have to have two two uh words
uh instead of having elements all over
the all all over the
place um and
um uh let's see
um I less than J but Pi
I less than
PJ oh I don't know what's wrong with
that let's
see
um well I
don't here's here's another thing about
that in the last sentence here or the
last paragraph We have shown then that
at least one element of L of c and P
namely that given by C plus KP as
above
now now namely is usually used to sort
of say um um in other
words and um and so when we have that
we'll tend to think it's going to be
parallelism with what we have shown so
we have shown then that but now so so so
there's we're using that here here it's
that given by in other words here I
would say uh the element or something
like that you know namely the element
given you know I have to figure out
where the namely is coming back to so
namely the element given by because this
that would is it uh I sort of it seems
namely that where we showing something
else it seems to me going
on um but this is this is so that a
person again can read it in one pass uh
is without when you see this that you
don't know uh you got the wrong
prediction of the
future usually when you're using you're
saying please push the please push the
button semicolon no I don't no I don't
think so we'll have more examples of
namely as we go
on uh here's an here's a homework
assignment that I wanted to mention um
uh numbered everything now maybe that
was the word processor did that but uh
uh every every single display was
numbered I don't think that's the you
know that's a wise ideaa you're losing
some of the uh Effectiveness and and U
you're going to be up in the thousands
by the time you get to the end of the
chapter
um now you
um the uh word non-empty was given with
a hyphen here and uh non- negative with
a hyphen there and as I said the other
day the these hyphens
are um
are are tending to be dropped these days
some books will still use them but most
but I think this The Hyphen in these
words disappeared about about uh uh late
60s and something like that um on on a
word processor unfortunately you have
only one symbol for both a hyphen and a
minus sign and uh it's usually too long
for a hyphen and too short for a minus
sign but got to live with it
um the parenthesis here that this is
copied from the the uh what was in the
what was given but it's really not
necessary to have a parenthesis around
the around it and it makes the formula
unnecessarily complicated so I would
leave off those
parentheses uh in fact that meant here
that somehow it seemed that they after
subtracting one from K still had
parenthesis around the CI minus CJ which
was which was not um
necessary uh and so those parenthesis
seem to be seem to leading to
clutter
um uh here's a use of the word
I and uh I see that Mary CLA sort of
defends the use of I in in technical
writing instead of saying we in
and in in her book and uh I guess we'll
have
to disagree about that one because uh uh
and maybe the it's not too it's not
really bad but I think in a lot of cases
the the the reader isn't the reader
isn't going to be that interested in the
person who's presenting it but was more
interested in the Cooperative uh uh work
of of of uh working together to prove
the the result instead of instead of
being impressed by how the author proved
it question on that uh yeah um you said
in your pointers that we means you the
reader and me the author what if there's
more than one author and you don't mean
you the reader and me the author you
mean just me the author well well then
you get then you get the the the great
luxury of being able to use it
Ambiguously and and uh and so you can
let them think anything they want um no
I don't know
um it's uh I would still prefer the the
uh the teamwork aspect of it I I think
of when I when I read a paper I also
recommend the same the same thing for
reading is that it's a um imagine that
you put yourself in the mind of the
author or you you try to solve it before
you see how what the solution is and but
uh you're thinking about how to solve
the problem and then when you get the
solution it's really something that that
sort of uh was partly your contribution
to as well as the office I don't know
there are situations where that's just
not appropriate that you can't expect
the reader to anticipate you at all
you're just giving definitions or
something I know so then you have to you
have to add add extra Clauses to to make
it unambiguous and and now that you know
the Chinese language is so much nicer
than English in this way because in
Chinese in Chinese most of the words are
neutral in the first place and you only
add qualifi you don't have feminine and
masculine you know you don't have plural
and singular uh you just add that on if
it matters uh and uh if we had a
language like that then we would be then
you know then we could then we could do
these things but still we when we have
we can use the same idea so it shouldn't
you know so in the case where we do have
the chance to use it Ambiguously then we
can add another phrase to disambiguate
it when it when it matters the way they
do in China question yeah what about
something like the author or
theth yeah uh yes the author uh well
this is this this tends to this is this
is formal but I but um it um it it can
be it can be done well um
in it it would be
um uh it I I would say for example uh if
you're writing a paper with two authors
and and one of them uh uh proved
something earlier or something like this
you might you might say uh uh one of the
authors peren initials or you would say
the first author or something like this
I would hesitate to say the senior
author um only at Harvard you know
no another comment on this one um uh
let's see in seven B C1 okay now here
you see this is what happens when you
put three dots very close together and
there's no comments but that's not my
what I wanted to get in here I wanted to
to say I would insert the word let here
let C and seven be this and K be this in
other words and let k i I just would you
know it's not strictly speaking
necessary but it's it sure helps to
repeat the word there and and and make
the parsing of the sentence
um clear um there's a typo here this
coverting this is something about the
CIA but uh we but we don't you know
that's just a typo no uh the word got is
something that uh is uh is is raises
hackles in the in all high school
writing classes and uh um and um it's a
word that's you it's a it's a good past
tense of get and so on but uh why should
we use past tense
um uh we have to think about
tenses um
and and uh um but I think here it's it's
it it's reached we if it was past tense
we would still use the word reached or
something like this or and I would
probably say have reached uh passive uh
uh what is it called past perfect tense
oh
well um
uh I would put a coal in there and so on
but the word got is definitely a losing
losing one in that place okay Don yeah
why not just stick to the present tense
for almost already yeah um it's uh uh
it's a uh uh it's something that that
you can you there there's there's two um
there's there's two ways to go and
either one is defensible but you should
you should stick with with one you have
and uh like I I discussed this once with
ACM editorial office they said our copy
editors like to keep to present tense
everywhere on the other hand if you get
a longer article you really can it makes
sense to dis to distinguish between
something that's going to occur in a
later section is something in an earlier
section and say we saw this before and
we will see something else and uh makes
a lot of sense to think of the of the
paper also being read sequentially so so
it turns out so so I I tend to think in
a shorter paper I get by with present
tense and and uh and U but it's hard
sometimes to to have the same
effectiveness of the of the past now I'm
a Believer in using the language the way
it was for the things that it evolved to
to serve and and uh language has these
tenses in it and so what so uh um how
many uh hand I mean there are how many
handcuffs should we wear uh uh or or
shouldn't we allow ourselves to use the
things in the other things in a language
and so we're U you know I'm saying maybe
you shouldn't say I uh because but but
but we is
okay um uh but I is also very good in a
in in any paper where where there's a
reason for the author to be to be of of
of concern to the to the reader and
maybe any paper is is that way but maybe
not maybe the the the the material in
the paper is more interesting than the
Persona of the author um but I
uh so so having tenses can be can be a
help but but it it's if uh if if you
find that it that that uh you've got
many tenses going on then it's then it
can be more confusing than than helpful
same with any any any good tool you can
over overdo it typography you can you
know you can use 20 fonts and so on it's
much better to use one font then but
sometimes uh using bold italic and so on
is a help uh carry it to extreme
snow uh I see I've run out of time
already I thought I was going to get
through this this whole pile of papers
well Friday we'll finish them I think
there's a lot of other interesting
things
um in
there
for
e